Activision has finally revealed more
details about Modern Warfare 2's spec
ops mode and we want to talk all about
it
Modern Warfare 2 spec ops mode is a
two-player Co-op experience so make sure
to share this video with the friend
you're playing with because I'm sure
they'll want this info too at launch
Modern Warfare 2 spec ops mode will
initially feature three missions these
will all be large scale missions that
take place on al-mazra the new map
location for Warzone 2.0 the three
missions are as follows bad situation a
stealth-based mission that requires
players to infiltrate a town in the dead
of night to uncover Intel and evidence
left behind by the enemy vehicle escape
with the help of a vehicle players must
navigate through the streets of a suburb
to destroy multiple Sam turrets and then
rush to the X-File plane to escape
Observatory defense a survival mode that
requires players to defend an
observatory from increasingly difficult
waves of enemies attempting to detonate
bombs in Spec Ops players will have
access to a backpack to store equipment
and one of three kids spec ops kits are
similar to having a set of perks field
upgrades and kill streaks in multiplayer
these include assault a kit focused on
increased armor with an armor box field
upgrade medic a kit focused on quicker
revives and a stem pistol field upgrade
for range instant revives and engineer a
kit focused on better equipment usage
with a snapshot Pulse Field upgrade to
see nearby enemies these kits are
leveled up by earning Stars through
missions and Mission related challenges
which the publisher says gives all three
of these launch missions plenty of
replayability Activision also mentioned
that players will want to complete the
spec ops missions to have at least one
kit leveled up to rank 5 before raids
arrived post-launch on December 14th as
part of the season one reloaded update
while it doesn't specify why presumably
this means kids will be factored into
raids which are described as being a
direct continuation of the campaign
those with digital pre-orders of the
game will receive Early Access to Modern
Warfare 2's campaign starting on October
20th additionally Activision announced a
whole set of Modern Warfare 2 campaign
rewards that players can earn for
completing the campaign during the Early
Access period so in the comments let me
know what you're doing to prepare for
the release of Modern Warfare 2 and I
will catch you tomorrow
foreign